hey guys we're at the United Terminal at
Newark Liberty International Airport and
we're gonna try to eat at as many
restaurants as humanly possible
in just six and a half hours to go on
what might be the craziest airport
layover food challenge ever
Sequoyah I just flew from across the
country and we invited our friends Casey
and Andrew from BuzzFeed New York
because there's tons of new and cool
restaurants iron chef's Michelin star
chefs Food Network judges right here at
the United
[Music]
thoughts for the day how many
restaurants are we gonna go to like I
think eight probably do at least like a
dozen ambitious I know I'm gonna say six
and a half the half being drinks
[Music]
may the games begin
[Music]
we get some stuff yeah yeah yeah there's
really nothing like a fresh croissant
[Music]
here's the stop number one
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys spot - ramen what are you
guys getting it was processing how many
options offices we talked about her oh
[Music]
yeah looks just like the picture this is
the best I like here yeah that's my vote
we're gonna make our own sushi box reach
get warmer we do one of the big good big
food big one yeah I'm into the salmon
roll everything they've got here looks
awesome yeah Oh chop sticks we need up
okay Casey hey what's up B yeah yeah
self-checkout I'm gonna pay with my
United miles
[Music]
cheers Cheers may your sushi be fresh
always we're doing this properly we're
making like soy sauce with the wasabi
Andrew please how do we feel about this
guys
honestly the sushi is great but I'm
gonna have to give this best view check
out this view here today scary time is
it all right so we got tots wedges we
got the fries we got four burgers wander
classic look how 3/4 these Sequoyah 30
wow it's so good I would have to say the
Cali burger is the most surprising bite
of the day it was a lot more flavorful
and wonderful than I imagined it would
you say your burger is no wonderful I
know that one yes I guess it is
wonderful I think we got like two hours
left go to another yeah there's lots of
other stuff yeah Tallyho that will you
marry break yeah
[Music]
thank you thank you firm it's good no I
don't know half more hours gonna do it
how we can do it we're pretty far off as
far as 12 spots bakery ramen sushi
burgers here plenty counting coffee -
that's a Bloody Mary scale probably fill
about this point right not a 10 for me
yeah it's good it's spicy but just wrong
good accessories are we gonna go say
best you're catching on yeah best okay
along I'm into that
you guys I get this one
highly recommend the body marry
[Music]
there's a burrata pizza I'm going vegan
you have to check ordering so who's
paying for the check thank you oh snap
tea that looks so good but best for
sharing maybe best with Gary yes
oh so cool yeah this is our last stop
you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to the airport slower food challenge
what's our what's our superlative most
relaxing most that's the best prep for
white men white I like that I typically
don't get to the airport early because I
don't think there's a lot to do but it's
kind of changed my perception over yeah
how much there actually is to do I was
surprised and they said that they'd made
me everything disguise I'll definitely
be at the airport six and a half hours
early a good time yeah but it's just a
quiet I got a thank you it's been a real
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]